[Musique]
le confort terrestre à un confort qui
s'inspirent souvent de l'espace
quelquefois plus qu'originale c'est
actuellement à paris au salon des arts
ménagers que l'on peut le trouver des
dizaines et des dizaines d'idées de
meubles de salle de bains classique et
d'avant garde comme celle-ci
transparente vous allez le voir très
agréable à l'oeil en fibres synthétiques
à travers les stands celle étalage
d'objets dont le but est oric et de
faciliter le travail ménager utile
certainement indispensable c'est à vous
mesdames d'en juger
quoique aux arts ménagers les hommes ont
aujourd'hui enfin gagné leur mot à dire
c'est bien à eux qu'incombe la tâche de
réparer les pannes de tous ces objets si
joli à regarder mais dont les femmes ne
comprennent que rarement le
fonctionnement mais le clou de cette
exposition c'est peut-être la machine à
laver la vaisselle et le linge
il est cependant recommandé de changer
l'eau entre les deux opérations mais
qu'elle est dans ce monde moderne
l'attitude des hommes face aux travaux
ménagers et lâche-t-il de temps en temps
la vaisselle jamais comparaison
à
entre tarde de rentrer cinq lycées
pendant ma rentrée
quel est votre rôle a assez d'admirer la
balle qui fait la bct
alors
alors qu'en pensez vous madame de ce que
vient de vivre votre mari normal toutes
les femmes seront elles de cet avis il
faut certainement douter et les hommes
être quand même bon gré mal gré leurs
épouses à cette tâche fastidieuse tel
monsieur chevalier secrétaire général du
salon bien entendu faire la vaisselle
hasebe souvent mais l'essuyer chaque
fois que notre aide ménagère d'étape
santé en affrontait la paix c'est bien
je les suis très simple est-ce que vous
pensez que l'entrée des appareils
électroménagers dans la vie a changé la
vie de la famille en eux c'est certain
en libérant la femme d'un certain nombre
de besogne fastidieuse ou pénibles les
appareils ménagers
on fait gagner un temps précieux qu'elle
peut employer à la culture et aussi à
s'occuper et de son mari et de ses
enfants
ils ont aussi transformé l'atmosphère du
foyer il n'est que de se rappeler ce
qu'était le jour de la lessive dans une
bonne famille bourgeoise il ya cinquante
ans ce débordement cette mauvaise humeur
l'homme
en bénéficient bien entendu on rentre le
soir il tombe une femme repose et
souriante
le coquin est agréable au lieu de
trouver une femme exténué
georges est allé se coucher
[Musique]